le grand retour d'astérix et obélix et
le 33e album et il sort demain dans
toute l'europe alors on ne connaît pas
encore l'histoire le secret est bien
gardé on sait qu'il ya des romains des
sangliers est aussi un plan marketing
digne d'une production hollywoodienne
pour ce nouvel album
marie pierre farkas pascal stelletta
rayon librairie à l'heure du laitier
répétition générale avant l'invasion
cette nuit astérix débarque dans toute
la france et 27 pays d'europe
on connaît le titre de l'album où le
reste de la cecc top secret n'écoutant
que notre courage nous avons demandé à
une main innocente de lever une partie
du mystère et l'on découvre que les
gaulois sont menacés par une grosse
boule inquiétante que des héros venus
d'autres bandes dessinées vous et se
courir voilà pour l'intrigué pour les
ventes
y a pas de suspense on peut parler de
l'équivalent probablement avec harry
potter peut-être voire même un peu plus
c'est plus fort que tintin c'est plus
fort que tout le monde sait c'est des
chiffres colossaux qui sont abstrait en
plus de 300 millions d'albums vendus
dans le monde sont vingt langues et
dialectes
c'est même des chiffres mais je ne peux
pas les conceptualisations sais pas ce
que ça veut dire c'est en 45 ans un
succès pareil si c'est unique quoi et
comme toutes les belles histoires cela
commence par une rencontre en 1951 rené
goscinny arrive des états unis avec un
rêve devenir walt disney il rencontre
albert uderzo ils créent ensemble de
nombreux héros un seul est éternel il
est petit rebelle baulois gras chaud
mais fidèle en amitié on a été très
étonné quand on a commencé à savoir que
ce personnage présent non seulement aux
enfants et aux plus grands
goscinny bon teint et maurice et dans le
cas du dr dos que c'est un très grand
dessinateur et tous les deux formaient
un espèce de couple
fabuleux uderzo a écrit puis dessiner
huit albums en solo depuis la mort de
goscinny en 1977 le fils d'immigré
italien a bâti son empire
mais il prend ses vacances ici au milieu
de ses trophées
astérix et obélix que vous retrouvez ce
soir dans le magazine envoyé spécial
avec un portrait justement du
dessinateur uderzo envoyé spécial à
partir de 20h50 avec françoise joly et
guilaine chenu